you
hello my name is Matt you're watching
code Tech and tutorials this is this my
new thing
just getting but I have a one-take
wonder for you guys today and hopefully
it turns out ok and if you're watching
this it probably did because I decided
to post it but who knows sometimes you
just got to let the internet judge you
you know some sometimes you just gotta
go that route
no I know I said I was supposed to do
some other tutorials but I'm still
working on those I really don't want to
release anything that's not quite ready
so more in the works if you want to get
those early maybe consider checking out
my patreon I'm gonna release a lot of my
stuff a day or two early on there but
there's no sense in doing it quite yet
although I'm prepping for it because I
don't have I don't think there's anyone
on there yet it's fairly new I haven't
really talked about it yet but it would
really mean a lot if I could get any any
source support on there I don't really
know how to ask and oh yeah it'd
actually feel all that comfortable
asking so let's get to the crux of this
particular video and what I want to talk
about and this comes from my experience
and my thoughts and a lot of my studies
and beuter science starting new jobs in
the computer science e world and also
just from my studies in psychology about
things so the thing is it's about how we
treat each other you know it's a big
topic in the world so I guess that's
fitting too
there's a there's a lot of things coming
down about that and really the whole
thing I really wanted to say is just to
be really nice to new developers so I
know it's it's really easy when you've
been doing it for awhile to see a
newcomer and thank all they're so bad
and maybe I'll just tell them how bad
they are and then their reaction well
yeah if they're really stubborn they'll
keep going but if they're not they'll
just quit so the last thing we want is
more developers quitting because there's
already a lack of developers especially
a lack of good developers and that's a
trend I've been noticing as the more I
get into the world and now by saying
that I'm not saying
I'm a good developer actually I think
I'm comparatively speaking I'm probably
not very good but that's neither here
nor there I do seem to have the aptitude
so as long as I keep working on it
eventually I'll get good now I've kind
of had the luxury of most people being
pretty nice to me but I've heard a lot
of horror stories about starting a first
job and just the training being abysmal
and no one really helping the new coders
how get to know things and kind of just
being expected to know everything when
obviously you wouldn't because that's
just not how this world works you just
don't magically know everything about
coding about environments and I've also
recently observed that there's there's
very few standards if you go to a
different place a different company or
maybe you're just trying to do something
on your own and trying to figure out
what the standard is for the community
you figure out that with about
everything there there is no there is no
standard everybody's doing something
different some people collaborate and
kind of do the same thing but it's still
the Wild West and software development
is what from what I can tell because
I've been trying to figure out for weeks
now how everyone should be doing their
C++ libraries and the conclusion I came
to is that everybody just does it
however they feel like and there's
really no standard that's that's that's
what I've come to with that so how does
an how's a newcomer approached something
like that where the standard is there is
no standard they're not gonna know
anything and they need to be taught and
hopefully they can be taught in a nice
way that doesn't deter them because
something something interesting is
happening in our world right now and
it's it's viewable and a lot of
different to industries but I think I
can't remember who pointed this out but
this isn't my original thought someone
pointed out that software development is
being dumbed down so much
I mean make sure I wear this right and I
don't think dumb down is the right word
so software development there are
basically fewer and fewer like true
programmers out there that really
understand the science behind what's
going on with the memory and all that
and the math and behind all that and
they would rather just use a library or
something that just does it all for them
and sure I can understand that you know
when you're new to it you wanna you kind
of want to take the easy approach but
what happens is they end up getting
deterred and they never dive deep enough
to truly understand and like you know
improve and reinvent things because
things always need improved and
reinvented we can't keep the same
standards for like 20 years
because things have just changed so much
so that's where the problem is coming in
as new coders they maybe learn spy thon
and learn a little bit of this at that
and pick a language that noobs like to
start with and then after that they're
done maybe they make a little game but
they don't even they don't even come
close to starting to understand what it
takes to build a new language or make
your stuff operate properly with a no
memory management works and stuff like
that that's just because they don't want
to go any deeper and I think the reason
is is just because it's such a cruel
harsh environment to be a software
developer and by that I mean you just
you just can't find help you go on Stack
Overflow you ask your new question you
get 10 down votes and 5 people yelling
at you 3 reports and you're just like I
just want to know how to properly
include a header file man well you don't
have to you don't have to do this to me
you don't have to like SWAT me and you
know I mean I'm exaggerating here but
you get the point right it's being a new
software developer is already
intimidating enough and when you just
try to ask a question to figure out
something that might be simple to
someone who's been doing it for a long
time you get berated and
basically just beaten to the ground it's
I want to say again that I have seen
this happen more than it's happened to
me I have definitely got a few there's
my guess is maybe been a few times when
I got that out you don't know this you
should know this I can't believe you
don't know this type of thing which
wasn't that bad but it's like you know
and yeah at some point you know there's
there's always a point where you don't
know something and you have to learn it
and if you see someone at that stage you
shouldn't be mean to him you should
maybe help him along or at least just
hold in your native bitter thoughts
about whatever is making you so bitter
from doing software development so long
which brings me to another point why are
why do you so many software developers
become so bitter and crazy I don't know
if that's the thing I just seems like
there's a lot of them seems like it's a
thing that eventually software
developers are just like you know I've
been doing this for a long time I don't
even care anymore and I don't really
ever want to get to that but I see that
a lot too and maybe it has something to
do with how everybody's treating each
other so you know it's just a bunch of
cool little nerdy stuff we can just you
know we could just be a little cooler
about it and not not be so mean to noobs
I guess that's my whole point it's just
to be nice new software developers
answer their questions help them out a
little bit at least point them in the
right direction rather than making fun
of them because yeah it sucks to have to
ask you know it sucks to have to go ask
for help when you're come when your
programs not compiling and then someone
looks at it and says you missed a
semicolon that that is from the
developer who missed the semicolons
point of view and had to go ask for help
they couldn't find it and then someone
just finds in a so simple and stupid
that is already humiliating enough so
just just leave it at that
I have story I have one story that I can
think of I'll just tell you I was I was
at a job and I was doing something I was
working on implementation of some new
feature and I was a little stuck and I
was like yeah I could sit here for like
hours trying to figure it out or I could
just go ask someone that probably knows
so I went and asked someone who probably
knows and it turns out I was doing
something that was obviously not wise
and as soon as someone pointed it out to
me
it clicked immediately I just didn't see
it before and but you know they were
really polite to me about it too people
tend to be applied to me maybe it's
because I look somewhat like guilfoyle
or something I don't know but that's
cool I do appreciate that so the thing I
was missing was I was just basically
overflowing some memory no I don't
explain this it was really just a see
out debug statement and the way it was
like translating the data was take
starting to take up gigs of memory which
was not supposed to happen so yeah it
was the way I was like unwrapping this
giant file and trying to see how parts
of it and once someone pointed it out to
me before they even said anything else I
was I knew immediately like oh yeah this
is definitely what's causing it I can't
believe it and see this earlier and it
was just a really stupid thing so you
know I really appreciated that they were
nice about it and you know it's funny a
lot of times when you're in that in the
midst of your project and digging in
deep eventually you just get stuck on
something and you just need to walk away
and come back with a clear head and
you'll see it you already knew it you
just wasn't clicking because there's so
much going on there's so many layers
going on you're all gonna tap often
having to think about 7 to 14 things at
once and eventually your mind just kind
of like I can't take it anymore you're
gonna go like take a break so all right
be cool you guys hope everyone's doing
well out there keep coding I'll see you
in the next video